moi je me souviens quand tu faisais tes
premières vidéos à la maison dans des
conditions qui étaient pas terrible mais
tu foisonnais d'idées et puis rien
n'était impossible quoi c'est toujours
le même motur une idée et allez hop on y
va mais tu sais ce que je trouve
essentiel c'est que malgré le succès tu
as gardé ta bienveillance voilà Squeezie
c'est finalement pas très compliqué et
moi Lucas je suis fier de ce que tu fais
et de ce que tu es et pareil pour
Florent j'ai de la chance d'avoir deux
gars formidables allez bisous mes amours
et merci Hugo c'est une super W mon père
vra c'est vra qu' est his il a raison
quand il dit que Squeezie c'est pas si
compliqué en vrai ouais c'est pas si
compliqué en fait en soi c'est comme il
dit mon père c'est juste des idées une
envie de créer des choses et de le
montrer aux gens et c'est aussi simple
que ça et il a aussi raison en fait il
dit que chaque personne a eu son
importance là-dedans et je le disais
tout à l'heure sur ce truc de
bienveillance moi je pense que c'est les
gens qui m'ont rendu bienveillant je
pense qu'à la base je l'étais pas
j'étais très névrosé beaucoup de
complexes et cetera et que les gens
m'ont vraiment aidé à me construire et à
et être plus serein merci Lucas c'était
trop bien merci he ça m'a aimu c'était
beau ce petit message ça m'a aimu